[Music]
why you read
[ __ ] because i like to read and this is
a really good book
you're a really good [ __ ] [ __ ] why you
got to bother me man
because i'm not doing very well at
school
i'm reading at a third grade level i
really don't want to get left back
so when i see somebody reading for fun
it makes me feel that much more stupid
and then i get mad
[Music]
um i didn't know that i thanks so much
for opening up to me
set up queer i understand why i mean why
you got to go there
i've been having sexual fantasies about
some of the other guys at school
give me that i'm afraid of these
feelings and what they might mean
it's like because i hate myself so much
i got to point that hate outward
towards you
[Music]
you understand this on such a deep level
that you i don't know
now i'm going to punish you physically
for acknowledging my emotional problems
i was going to say if you understand
yourself so well then maybe you should
try working
on changing it of course i want to
change it
but it's the only defense mechanism i
have against deeper more terrifying
problems buried inside of me lucky my
dad's here
get the damn talk son i need to take you
home and beat on you because i hate
myself
and you look like your mother who left
me and i'ma block out the guilt i feel
over mistreating you with the river of
vodka
[Music]
i'm gonna internalize that and
unknowingly transfer it on to you
tomorrow
[Music]
coming reluctantly
you